[Music]
Well, Nvidia have done it once again.
They released yet another GeForce 50
series GPU without any reviews. This
time they announced the GeForce RTX
5050. They said it would be available on
July 1st and that was it really. There
were no early reviews. There were even
no reviews on July 1st. Instead,
consumers would have to go in blind. But
you know what? You don't have to go in
blind to today's sponsor. Today's
sponsor spot is brought to you by UGG
Green and their Nassync DXP 4800 Plus.
Designed to be as userfriendly as
possible, the NASYNC DXP 4800 Plus
addresses the issue of high cost,
limited storage cloud services by
storing and backing up all of your data
locally. The 4ay model offers a maximum
112 terbyte capacity with excellent
third-party hard drive and SSD support.
Transfer speeds of up to 1,250 megabytes
pers are possible, which is the
equivalent of 1 TBTE about every 20
minutes, while the use of an Intel 12th
gen Core i5 processor allows for
effortless multitasking. As I said, this
is a beginner friendliness, and part of
that is a simple step-by-step guide,
which will get even the most novice
users up to speed quickly. And on top of
that, there's appfriendly support for
Windows, iOS, Android, and smart TVs.
With a UG Green NAS, you can also
effortlessly classify photo albums. And
the NASC has a built-in AI smart
recognition and classification function
that allows you to search photos by
simply entering search keywords such as
pets, fruits, vehicles, and loads more.
So, if you'd like to learn more about UG
Green's latest NAS and their Amazon
Prime Day deals, please check the link
in the video description.
Okay, so the first time Nvidia did this
with a GeForce 50 series product was
with the RTX 5060Ti 8 GB. The 16 GB
model, apparently that was fine. Nvidia
was okay with using benchmarks for that
model, but the 8 GB version, no sir. You
just had to assume that it worked the
same way. And the play there was to
block partners such as MSI and ASUS from
sending out 8 GB cards to reviewers. and
even the retail availability that was
delayed for a few days allowing the 16
GB reviews to permeate the internet. The
plan worked though as there was very
little 8 gigabyte coverage the 5060 Ti
and what did appear was heavily delayed.
Then for the RTX 5060, so the nonTi
model of which there was only an 8 GB
version, Nvidia let review samples slip
out for that one, but this time opted to
block the driver access instead. And
that's something that they can much more
easily control on their end. And it
meant that despite having the hardware
in hand, it was practically impossible
to use it. Then for the icing on the
cake, they released it during the
Computex trade show when most of the
world's tech media, ourselves included,
were overseas in Taiwan. So now we have
the third 8 GB Blackwell GPU, the RTX
5050. And for this one, there was no
review samples at all. So, not having
the driver was a non-issue for this one.
And in fact, we couldn't even purchase
it until several days after it was meant
to appear on shelves. So, a bit of an
odd release, but certainly not the
strangest thing Nvidia's ever done.
Anyway, the good news is, if you can
call it that, I have an RTX 5050, which
I paid a little over $500 Australian
for. So, certainly not the best
investment I've ever made, but we did
need a review after all. But before we
jump into the blue bar graphs, let's
quickly go over some of the specs. So,
the RTX5050 is set to cost $250 US,
making it $50 US cheaper than the
RTX5060.
It uses a smaller GB 207 die with 16.9
billion transistors in a 149 mm die. So,
it's 17% cheaper than the RTX 5060, but
there are 33% fewer cores. And along
with that, Nvidia's also downgraded the
GDDR7 memory of the other Blackwell GPUs
to GDDR6 for the 5050, reducing the
memory bandwidth by almost 30% to 320 GB
pers. And this means the 5050 could be
considerably slower than the 5060 and to
the degree that we'll see it offer much
worse value, which will be very
disappointing if true. Now, for testing,
a lot of the games have been benchmarked
using higher quality presets, and this
is because the data is used to compare
with a wide range of products all the
way from an RTX 5050 right up to the
RTX5090.
That said, though, while retesting with
low or medium quality presets would
improve the frame rates, you can expect
to find very similar margins between
competing products. For example, the RTX
5050, 5060, and 9060 XT8 GB will all
scale in a very similar fashion, meaning
the overall findings will be much the
same. All of that said, if there is
enough demand, I will retest a select
range of budget GPUs using lower quality
presets and a separate content piece.
Then there's the CPU. And of course, I
will be using our standard GPU test
system, which has a 9800 X3D because
again, we want the data for all GPUs to
be comparable. And I will actually
produce a video soon where I compare all
current and previous generation GPUs.
But from a benchmarking perspective,
removing the CPU bottleneck makes the
most sense. And this test method really
only becomes problematic in outlier
cases where the CPU overhead is
excessive, like what we see in some
games with the B580. In the case of the
RTX 5050 and 9060 XT, though, we would
see very similar margins between these
two products with a Ryzen 57500F,
for example. And that's because you're
almost always going to end up being GPU
limited. So, just keep that in mind.
Anyway, let's move on to the benchmarks
to find out what the RTX 5050 has for
us.
First up, we have Marvel Rivals at
1080p. And here, the 50/50 was good for
50 fps. So, playable performance. And of
course, you can lower the quality
preset. That did make it 25% faster than
the RX7600, which is a similarly priced
previous generation product, and it even
managed to match the ARK B580.
However, the 8 GB 9060 XT was 25%
faster. Though, given it cost 20% more,
that's really only a slight advantage
for the Radeon GPU in terms of value.
So, in this particular test, the 50/50
looks decent. It's certainly not going
to blow anyone away with its
performance, even for $250 US, but I'd
say it's passable here, or near enough,
too. Next up, we have Star Wars Jedi
Survivor. And again, the performance at
1080p is solid. 70 fps on average,
though that's only enough to roughly
match the ARK A770, so the older ARC GPU
and the old Radeon RX 6650 XT. So
certainly not amazing in that sense. And
worse still, this time the 9060 XT 8 GB
was 41% faster. That's a massive
increase given the difference in price.
Moving on to Cyberpunk 2077. This is
another game where the RTX 5050 delivers
reasonable performance using the high
preset at 1080p. 72 FPS on average is
certainly playable, though relative to
several other entry-level products, it's
not particularly great. For example,
this makes the 50/50 just a few frames
faster than the old RTX 3060, while it
again matched the 6650 XT and AR770.
The very disappointing results though
are seen when comparing to the 9060 XT 8
GB as here the 50/50 gets slaughtered.
The Radeon GPU was 54% faster rendering
111 FPS on average resulting in a much
more impressive experience. Now moving
on to Hogwarts Legacy which has also
been tested using the high preset. So
the second highest preset, we see that
the RTX 5050 is again good for 70 FPS on
average, which in this example is the
same level of performance seen from the
ARC B580 and RTX 4060 along with the
6650 XT. As a result, the 960 XT 8 GB
was again massively faster, delivering
50% better performance with an average
of 105 FPS and again it cost just 20%
more. So, in terms of value, this does
spell disaster for the new budget
GeForce GPU. For testing The Last of Us
Part One, the ultra preset is used as
most GPUs can deliver over 60 fps. And
we see that that's indeed the case with
the 960 XT8 GB, which ended up almost
40% faster than the RTX 5050. The 50/50
came in slightly slower than the RX7600,
but comfortably ahead of the 6650 XT.
So, not exactly amazing performance even
at $250 US. Now, Star Wars Outlaws
enables RA tracing by default. So, this
is a glimpse of what the RTX50 might
offer for those interested in RT
performance. We're looking at just 34
FPS on average here, which is the same
level of performance seen previously
from the RX7600
and ever so slightly better than the
AR770.
It also meant that the 9060 XT 8 GB is
almost 50% faster in this example,
rendering 50 FPS on average.
As was the case in Marvel Rivals, the
RTX 5050 is somewhat competitive in
Space Marine 2. Here, the 9060 XT 8 GB
was 22% faster. So, in terms of value,
they're quite similar. And in the end,
the 5050 was comparable to the RTX 4060
and 6T700 XT. So, not too bad, I guess.
Obviously, I'm not expecting the RTX
5050 to do all that well relative to the
9060 XT 8 GB in Call of Duty Black Ops
6, given Radeon GPUs typically perform
very well in this title. But just 60 fps
on average at 1080p is rather weak
performance and that made it barely
faster than the RTX 3060 and RX6600
and slower than the 6650 XT and ARC
B580. Meanwhile, the 960 XT 8 GB was
100% faster. Finally, the last game
we're going to look at the individual
results for is Clear Obscure Expedition
33. And here, the 9060 XT 8 GB was 38%
faster than the RTX 5050. Meanwhile, the
50/50 was comparable to the RTX 4060 and
7600 XT along with the ARC 580 and
RX7600.
Now, as noted earlier, the RTX 5050
features a 130W TDP and therefore
requires just a single PCIe power input.
For our testing, we're measuring the
power draw from both the GPU and CPU, as
this accounts for any CPU overhead. The
RTX 5050 consumes roughly the same
amount of power as the RTX 4060, meaning
it uses around 60 W less than the 9060
XT. So, a reasonable saving, though, of
course, it was much slower in our gaming
benchmarks. Speaking of which, here's
how the RTX 5050 performed on average at
1080p across all 18 games tested. For
the average frame rate, we're looking at
66 FPS on average, which disappointingly
made it 3% slower than the RX7600. So,
in other words, you're getting roughly
7600 performance for 7600 money. Though,
it is upgraded with better quality
upscaling. So, there is that. The big
problem for the RTX 5050 as I see it is
the 9060 XT8 GB which might cost $50 US
more. So that's a 20% premium. But the
Radeon GPU was a massive 44% faster on
average in our testing. Of course, I
don't recommend you waste money on any 8
GB GPU in 2025 and instead opt for the
16 GB version of the 960 XT. And while
that is considerably more expensive than
the 50/50, presumably you're keeping
whatever you buy now for at least the
next four years, meaning it's a
long-term investment. So spending more
on something that will actually last
seems like the smart play. And as an
example of that, if we look at the 1440p
data, we see that here the 9060 XT is
now 56% faster on average, which is a
result of the 960 XT handling the
increased load better, but also the PI
Express 16 bus does help smooth out a
few more of those VRAM related issues.
And then if we look at the 16 GB version
of the 960 XT, we see that on average it
was almost 80% faster than the RTX 5050
with 96% stronger 1% low performance,
making it the obvious budget choice for
me, but let's go take a close look at
value. Now,
first, here's a historic look at value
across the generations based on the
MSRP, which I'm aware hasn't always been
a thing. Anyway, if we look at a part
such as the Radar RX7600,
which was available at the $270 US MSRP
and then dropped down to $250. But if we
compare the RTX50 with the 7600's $270
US MSRP, we see that in terms of cost
per frame, it's barely an improvement,
reducing the cost per frame by a mere
5%.
Worse still, the 50/50 costs more per
frame than the 8 GB 5060 Ti. It's only a
3% increase, but value is meant to
increase as you work down the food
chain, not get worse. And even worse is
the fact that the 960 XT 16 GB, if it
was available at the $350 US MSRP, would
actually be better value. 7% better
value based on this data. And then, of
course, you have the 8 GB model, which
is 20% better value. A shocking result
for Nvidia's new budget GPU. So, all of
that looks very bad for the RTX 5050,
but let's go look at some realworld
retail pricing.
Okay, so here's a look at the models you
can currently buy at retail in the US.
In terms of value, the RTX 5050 is
slightly worse than the 16 GB 960 XT, 8
GB 5060Ti, and quite a bit worse than
the RTX 5060. Again, it costs 20% more
per frame than the 9060 XT 8 GB. So, if
you're okay with just 8 GB of VRAM, the
960 XT is a much better product. But
again, I'd recommend saving up for the
16 GB model as it is faster again and
it's a competent 1440p gamer. And of
course, it will stand up much better in
the future. In fact, it's doing so right
now. Then if we recalculate the cost per
frame, but this time based on the 1440p
data, we see the RTX 5050 actually ends
up costing 30% more per frame when
compared to the 16 GB 9060 XT. And
that's up from 20% seen at 1080p. So,
for those of you wanting to tackle
higher resolutions, or perhaps you might
want to do so in the future with higher
quality settings, or you just plan on
playing the latest and greatest games
moving forward, the 16 GB models are
going to end up representing far better
value.
Before we wrap this up, here's a quick
look at the MSI Shadow version of the
RTX 5050. It's a small dual fan card
with a plastic back plate. And after an
hour loop in F125, we saw a peak GPU
temperature of 73°, which is reasonably
cool. Though the fans were spinning at
1,900 RPM and could be very easily heard
over our case fans generating 38 dibels
of noise. So quite a poor result given
the card was sucking down just 131 W at
a clock speed of 2,850 MHz. So again,
quite poor results overall, but also
probably not surprising given the Shadow
uses an aluminium base plate with just a
single direct touch 6mm copper heat
pipe, and it is an MSRP card, so I don't
know how it stacks up with other MSRP
models. Okay, so there you have it. In
short, the RTX 5050 is a slightly slower
RTX 4060 at a slightly discounted price.
So that's an exciting upgrade after 2
years.
As for whether or not you should buy it
uh in the current market, I'm going to
say probably no. The RTX 5060 is only
20% more expensive, but offers a little
over 30% better performance. So, spend
more, you get better value. Uh the more
you spend, the more you save, guys. And
realistically, an even better deal
awaits from AMD with the 960 XT 8 GB,
which also cost 20% more. But in our
testing, it was a little over 40%
faster. Of course, the 8 GB 960 XT is
also a poor product that I highly
recommend you avoid and instead opt for
the 16 GB model, which is considerably
more capable and will hold its value far
better. In terms of cost per frame, the
16 GB 96T is also slightly better value
than the RTX 5050, and that's taking
into account the slightly above MSRP
price of $370 US. But even at a $130
US premium, it's quite clear that the
960 XT 16 GB is the way to go. And look,
I know it's far from a trivial price
difference. And unfortunately, not
everyone can just come up with that kind
of money. And if that's the case, then I
strongly recommend trying to dig deep
for that extra $50 for the 9060 XT 8 GB
or I suppose worst case, the RTX 5060,
as both of those products are better
value. The RTX50 really is a horribly
disappointing prospect for $250 US. At
that point, you might as well try your
luck on the secondhand market. As for
stuff like RA tracing performance, given
the RTX 5050 is generally a little bit
slower than the RTX 4060, you can
largely expect to find the same when it
comes to RT performance. I haven't
bothered to update the RT benchmark data
for all of the entry-level and low-end
GPUs as they generally can't do it very
well. So testing has been a low
priority, but here is one example using
what we call a transformative RT
experience in Cyberpunk 2077. Again, the
50/50 is slower than the 4060, which is
46 FPS on average at 1080p using quality
upscaling. So, not exactly what I'd call
a great experience. The only good things
you can say about the RTX 5050, is that
it consumes very little power, so
therefore runs cool and has the
potential to be very quiet. though the
MSI Shadow model that I purchased was
very basic and didn't have the best
cooler on it, but it is an MSRP model,
so perhaps that'll be the norm. Hard to
say having only looked at a single model
so far. Now, perhaps the most important
feature of the RTX It's very It's very
plasticky, isn't it? Anyway, the most
important feature of the RTX 5050, or
maybe the most important feature is the
fact that it delivers DLSS4 support to
the lowest price point yet. Sadly
though, I don't think that fact alone
makes it good value. I don't really
think it's good value at all because as
I said, you are just better off buying a
50 series product if you want to
maximize your investment while still
getting some DLSS4 goodness. So really,
that's the 50/50 in a nutshell. It's
very cheap, very plasticky, and not
worth buying, not just this particular
model. That goes for all RTX 5050s, at
least at $250 US. I think at $200 US,
it's probably becomes a good buy. But
yeah, 250 I'd just Well, unfortunately,
you're being upsold to either a RTX 5060
or a 9060 XT8 GB. I'm not happy the fact
you have to spend an extra uh $50, but
that's just what you want to do or what
you have to do if you want to maximize
your investment. And then even then, you
probably got to spend a bit more money
cuz the 16 GB 960 XT is as cheap as I
would recommend you go. So, that's just
the state of things at the moment. I
wish there were better value cards.
There just isn't. So, it is what it is.
I can only call it. I don't get to make
the rules. Anyway, that is going to do
it for the coverage of the RTX 5054.
Now, as I said, depending on demand, I
might do some low, medium testing, maybe
some CPU, GPU scaling stuff. We'll see.
Uh, yeah, if you like the video, you
know what to do. Subscribe for more
content. We have the join button,
Patreon. You get access to our exclusive
Discord server, monthly live streams,
behind the scenes content, and Q&A
stuff. So, check that out if you're
interested. But if not, that is
perfectly fine. And I would like to
thank you for watching this video. I'm
your host, Steve. See you again next
time.
[Music]